i have to talk to you a little bit about
you know this huge
moment where you practically broke the
internet certainly tick tock
and you decided to generously give the
fans
an explicit version of potential breakup
song
[Music]
what was it like re-recording that song
now in your 30s
and sort of giving it the r-rated
treatment i mean it was funny
it was it was interesting to like
dissect the song and
and kind of find uh a new fresh take on
it i mean it was it was great for aj to
be able to get into the studio
and remix it remaster it take out some
of the things in the track that
um i think just weren't necessary you
know we were able to kind of like
take down some of the auto tune that was
such a sound you know back in the day
that was
used in so many songs
it was just fun to give it like a
makeover and i think the fans that
that were able to connect with it um and
you know
i think a lot of them have been waiting
and wanting some kind of a explicit
version which is what
made us like laugh and and feel like we
needed to give this to the fans
it was perfect timing you know with the
having its moment on on tick tock and
then
us you know already being in the studio
making new music and then having
slow dancing you know release right
after that it was kind of just
perfect timing and we really couldn't
have created it better
we get out on the road in 2022 and we
hit you know a bunch of places overseas
and then we do the us as well so we've
got we've got like a good like four
months of touring for us ahead but
it's been a while since we've been out
on the road i'm really excited i have to
ask you i
i did a little bit of um uh math on the
song i counted
two f-bombs
[Music]
was there ever a world where you toyed
with the idea of
making it more explicit adding more
profanity
i think we felt like it it was good how
it was
and not going too crazy and that we were
just replacing words that were already
there
so we weren't really adding anything we
were just replacing the word that was
like
the you know pg virgin version of it and
then
putting in the the explicit except for
the fact it was my birthday
my stupid birthday
aj i think originally just thought it
would be the just
the f-bomb once and i was like aj
there's still a couple more in here that
we can do and she's like oh yeah i guess
he's right so
amazing and you know the the original
video is so iconic
was there ever a discussion about
re-recording or re-filming a new music
video for the song
yeah we talked about that um for a
second um but
again we were so kind of inundated with
our new music at that point in time and
we were doing
music videos for the new album and we
just didn't have the time
but yeah i mean i know a lot of people
that that love the
the the video and us and the white
backdrop and everything
paint pretty gosh i can't believe it
we're in our 30s
and for you to now see a whole new
generation of
fans discover your music popularize it
and make it go viral on tick tock i mean
what do you make of that
it's it's really wild i mean i feel like
i'm definitely not
part of that generation that is
so good at using that platform and it
comes so naturally to them i have to
like learn it a little bit
um but at the same time you know it's
great to see that
younger fans are getting turned on to
our music whether it's the old music or
this new music
um in these you know in these new ways
and
we're just you know we're just happy to
have them on board i mean they've
followed us for so many years even
throughout the time we weren't making
music and we were really focusing on our
acting projects
now you know being back with the new
record to touch the beats
it just feels really good to be back to
music it feels like it's our home it's
it's our first love
and you know we just can't wait to get
out on the road in 2022 now
i have to ask did you see the backstreet
boys and in sync
lip dubbing
what was your reaction i mean it's it's
pretty fantastic
it's it's so funny to to see
this like this resurgence of acts from
an era where it it was unlike any other
you know like the early 2000s was so
special
and aj and i were huge instinct fans and
backstreet too so seeing them do that
was just like
it was it was pretty funny i was like my
younger self would have just been like
no this isn't real you know i'm counting
on you minutes aren't you
hey i used to play softball you better
hold your breath good luck
i really really love this movie it's
just such
a nice slice of a rom-com that i think
the world could use right now
dollar cove how do you describe it i
describe it as
this really sweet love story between
two kind of opposite characters that
come from very different worlds you know
ali is a city girl and brodie is a small
town
boy and the two of them just find this
connection with each other
and you know they're a little bit at
odds at the beginning of our story
but by the end of it you know ellie's
kind of fallen in love with this small
town
and it's just it's really sweet it's
it's a great little love story
and it's set in a beautiful setting it
was shot in mystic connecticut which is
a darling town
it was great
you